où est ce qu'on va se retrouver comme ça
avec les enfants qu'est ce que l'on va
faire écouter la meilleure des choses
c'est d'en parler tout de suite avec
marc antoine tanguay d'allô prof
bonjourbonjour de semafo alors que bien
des gens se battent et qui m'ont dit oh
mon dieu ça nous inquiète deux semaines
de retard d'abord remettons les pendules
à l'heure deux semaines c'est pas la fin
du monde pour un enfant en année
académique non en fait c'est ça va être
gérée par le personnel enseignant ce
n'est pas la première fois dans
l'histoire que ça arrive qu'une
suspension de cours on fait des fois la
météo est pas évidente lui la crise du
verglas
d'autres exemples aussi où il avait eu
des suspensions de cours comme ça et ça
avait été rattrapé donc dans une
perspective de deux semaines je pense
que des enseignants vont pouvoir
s'ajuster puis réagir en conséquence
pour pro compromettre l'année et entre
temps ci à la maison vous devez
expliquer les divisions à trois chiffres
heureusement il ya le prof alors quels
sont les services que vous allez offrir
mais c'est exactement si on est dans un
terrain un peu inconnu mais nous on se
voulait rassurant dire aux gens vous
savez nous on est déjà à distance on
continue pleinement d'être opérationnel
alors n'hésitez pas à vous tourner vers
le site internet où il ya des milliers
de ressources pour expliquer par exemple
la division à trois chiffres et un très
bon exemple ou encore pour retrouver des
activités même pour occuper vos enfants
la maison mais de manière peut-être un
petit peu plus éducative bon parce qu'en
temps normal quoi vous êtes vous êtes
disponible de keller à quelle heure en
ligne mais notre site internet est
accessible en tout temps
c'est une ressource et 5000 contenu sur
notre site
on retrouve tout le primaire le
secondaire toutes les matières donc ceci
est accessible en tout temps et nos
enseignants restent disponibles aussi
l'histoire de semaine du lundi au jeudi
de 17h à 20h donc encore le sillon des
questions on s'attend peut-être une
petite accalmie lundi mardi mais on va
voir par la suite comment les jeunes
vont réagir comment les parents vont
réagir et quelles nouvelles on aura
aussi du milieu de l'éducation
mais nos enseignants restent accessibles
en poste par téléphone texto sur super
prof en ligne donc les services
continuent normalement et c'est ce que
s'est passé pour des plus petits je
pense même première deuxième troisième
année jusqu'au secondaire 5 il ya tous
les programmes et toutes les les
les présentations adaptés aux âges
positionnement exactement tous les
contenus d'apprentissage qu'on peut voir
à l'école se retrouve sur le site de nos
profs et on a des enseignants de tous
les niveaux pour répondre à n'importe
quelle question de peuvent se poser les
parents ou leurs enfants
bon est ce que ça coûte quelque chose
comment on fait c'est toujours à faire
gratuitement allô prof est un obnl qui
est financé par le ministère de
l'éducation et des partenaires privés
des fondations tous nos services sont
gratuits tous nos enseignants sont des
vrais enseignants qui travaillent en
principe dans les écoles de jour et en
ce moment ils sont encore plus
disponibles que jamais pour aider et
tout ça est offert gratuitement
l'ensemble la population québec
bon vous travaillez avec des écoliers de
jeu des adolescents j'ai pas eu la
chance de la positon voilà la question
mais si les enfants bientôt des parents
qui m'ont dit comment j'explique que
c'est un coronavirus que c'est une
maladie qui affecte peu les enfants
comment comment est-ce que ce que des
moyens de leur expliquer qu est ce que c
qui frappe dans le moment là cette crise
est pandémie oui tout à fait il ya des
moyens on peut si on pense à pluvieux
peut-être il ya là on voit la fameuse
courbe les deux courbes qui sont le plus
viral en ce moment c'est des
mathématiques que les élèves voient en
secondaire à personne secondaire 3
environ comment fait aborder ces notions
là qu'on va retrouver sur le site on
peut demander aussi aux enseignants
d'allô prof on a des orthopédagogues
également comment est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer une situation comme celle là
et on a toute une caisse une section en
biologie sur le site aussi pour trouver
de l'information sur le principe des
virus vous allez peut-être retrouver
quelques papas et mamans sur votre site
pour essayer de voir comment on va
expliquer tout ça ils sont les bienvenus
allô prof et réfléchie pour les enfants
les adolescents d'abord mais pour les
parents c'est un public super important
pour nous on est vraiment à leur écoute
merci d'être venu expliquer et rassurer
ses parents qui vont dire deux semaines
sans cela ce qu'est ce qu'on va faire
mais vous voyez un moyen de moyenner
merci beaucoup d'un plaisir